ontario schools will reopen to some 2
million children starting next monday
janna king is a teacher and a mom and is
torn i know that it's better for my
students when we're face to face but
it's crazy at school like i shouldn't
have 30 kids in my classroom and she
says a lot of kids don't keep their
masks on and not every classroom has
proper air filters yet but with support
from pediatricians groups ontario is
resuming in-person learning because of
the harm to kids mental health from
staying home we've seen the numbers of
mental health needs rising rapidly we
know that it helps students to be in
school for their mental and physical
health
out west most schools have already
reopened in-person learning is preferred
but how soon depends on the province in
british columbia alberta and
saskatchewan schools return to in-class
learning this week or last in the rest
of the country learning is still
happening mostly online but as of
january 17th manitoba ontario quebec pei
and nova scotia plan to reopen
classrooms new brunswick will stay
online at least till the 24th and
newfoundland and labrador is still
assessing it's not an easy call i don't
know what to do honestly on balance this
epidemiologist favors keeping schools
closed another couple of weeks anything
we do at the societal level
that reduces the strain on the hospital
system even a little bit is going to
have a positive impact but this
infectious disease expert leans towards
opening them instead of saying close
schools why don't we say
create safer schools yet he acknowledges
in ontario there's a risk this is the
largest sanctioned mass gathering event
in the province like you can't ignore
the potential for amplification of the
virus in this environment schools are
just one part of it as covid cases
skyrocket and hospitalizations climb
many provincial plans are in flux we
face many more i don't knows and i'm not
sure today than we have perhaps at any
point
in the in the pandemic journey to now
governments will have to be nimble as
the omicron wave grows and up to 5
million children across the country go
back to school eric sorensen global news
toronto